Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres la bande dessinée est-elle
toujours de la littérature de second
rang tout juste bonne dans le meilleur
des cas à divertir les enfants et dans
le pire allez desservoler non les choses
ont beaucoup changé depuis une
cinquantaine d'années on peut même dater
avec précision d'un jour de 1969 le
début de ce changement lorsque le
général de Gaulle a déclaré André
Malraux mon seul rival international
c'est Tintin ensuite quelques années
après a été créés le festival
d'Angoulême qui est devenu maintenant le
Festival de Cannes du 9e art il se
déroule d'ailleurs en ce moment et puis
encore une ou deux décennies et le prix
Pulitzer était décerné pour la première
fois à un album maos de Art Spiegelman
et aujourd'hui c'est l'apothéose dans
notre pays puisque les bulles sont
entrées dans deux institutions
naturel française vénérable l'Académie
des Beaux-Arts et le Collège de France
alors la bande dessinée est-elle devenue
un arbre majeur c'est de cela dont nous
allons discuter ce soir avec deux
figures de cet univers
Christophe Blain bonsoir
Christophe vous êtes l'un des
dessinateurs stars de la bande dessinée
française et commencer avec Johann
strain et Lewis trondel et puis ensuite
vous avez volé de vos propres ailes avec
Isaac le pirate
votre notoriété a franchi un palier
lorsque vous avez signé les dessins des
deux albums de Quai d'Orsay qui
racontait librement la vie de Dominique
de Villepin ministre des Affaires
étrangères mais là vous avez publié l'an
dernier très exactement avec Jean-Marc
Jancovici
le monde sans fin aux éditions d'argot
qui
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur le la crise climatique en 300
pages à peu près 1500 dessins très
drôles très didactique et qui a connu un
succès populaire énorme plus vous en
êtes à combien de ventes 700000 700000
c'est incroyable on va revenir à vous
tout de suite mais on va commencer avec
Benoît Peters bonsoir Benoît bonsoir
vous êtes vous avez grandi en Belgique
ce qui est plutôt de bonne augure quand
on s'intéresse à la bande dessinée votre
ami d'enfance est un auteur et
dessinateur de bandes dessinées François
schmitaine vous avez été l'élève de
Roland Barthe et je suis mais ensuite
l'étendue de vos talents et considérable
puisque vous avez publié une soixantaine
d'ouvrages et d'albums signés une petite
dizaine de films et de documentaires
alors vous vous intéressez aux
biographies aux essais aux albums aux
romans et en gros le compas de vos
curiosités va de Paul Valéry
ou robe grillé en passant par Tintin et
par Hergé dont vous êtes un grand
spécialiste vous êtes un grand
spécialiste de la bande dessinée c'est
même vous qui avez fait entrer la bande
dessinée au Collège de France puisque
vous y occupez la chair cette année de
création artistique et vous publiez
un petit livre dans son format 160 pages
mais remarquablement fait
remarquablement illustré qui est une
introduction à l'histoire de la bande
dessinée vous en racontez l'histoire
vous en fixé les enjeux vous en vous
vous montrez quelles sont ces grandes
figures pour qui ne connaît pas la bande
dessinée je crois que c'est la meilleure
introduction jamais publiée alors si
vous voulez bien on va reparcourir cette
histoire avec vous en commençant par le
début l'acte de naissance est-ce que
c'est la grotte de Lascaux est-ce que
c'est la Tapisserie de Bayeux est-ce que
c'est la légende de la vraie croix de
Pierrot de la franchiseka ou bien je
crois que c'est plutôt votre hypothèse
le début du 19e siècle la première
moitié du 19e siècle en Suisse oui pour
pour moi et pour beaucoup de
spécialistes c'est plutôt cela c'est
vrai qu'on essayait à un moment de
sortir la bande dessinée du ruisseau et
de dire la Tapisserie de Bayeux la
colonne Trajane c'est déjà de la Bandit
c'est déjà de l'image narrative bien sûr
mais la bande dessinée qui est
profondément à l'imprimé au
développement de la presse au
développement du livre illustré au 19e
siècle il y a donc ce Suisse Rodolphe
Topfer qui rêvait d'être peintre mais
qui avait une affection aux yeux qui ne
lui permettait pas dessiner assez
précisément mais il est même théâtre il
aimait écrire il aimait caricaturé et il
a fait de petits récits et c'est goethes
le grand écrivain allemand au soir de sa
vie qui découvrons les manuscrits là
encouragé à publier et donc c'était des
petits livres d'abord ces petits livres
ont très vite été piratés ils sont
arrivés à Paris ils ont été imités ils
ont été traduits et au fond tout au long
du XIXe siècle ce qu'on a longtemps
ignoré la bande dessinée s'est
développée avant de naître une deuxième
fois aux États-Unis voilà c'est ça alors
fin du 19e siècle Zig et puce Bécassine
fin du 19e siècle surtout les grands
américains c'est à dire l'œil Loki
little Némo crazy cat etc j'allais
revenir à ça parce que au 19e siècle le
genre se constitue mais l'essor
véritable de la bande dessinée c'est
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
c'est là qu'il y a trois grandes aires
géographiques les États-Unis
l'ensemble France - Belgique et le Japon
si on commence par les États-Unis c'est
incroyable les grands genres de la bande
dessinée le comique avec Crazy cat les
aventures avec flashboard et puis
surtout les super héros Batman Superman
etc naissent là-bas comment expliquer le
faveur et l'essor de la bande dessinée
aux États-Unis et quel impact cette
bande dessinée a-t-elle eu sur nous
alors ce qui est extraordinaire aux
États-Unis c'est que la bande dessinée
se développe dans la grande presse et
s'adresse à tous elle n'est pas destinée
prioritairement aux enfants quand on
regarde au début du siècle en France
c'est les illustrer c'est les illustrer
vraiment plutôt pour les petits alors
que aux États-Unis mandrez que Flash
Gordon little des mots s'adresse à tous
et donc profondément cette
transgénérationnelle c'est aussi la
magie de la couleur parce que les
journaux américains reproduisent en
couleur et le livre est tout à fait
secondaire puis à ce phénomène qu'on
appelle les qui n'ont rien à voir avec
des syndicats qui sont des agences de
presse qui diffusent d'abord partout à
travers les États-Unis puis dans le
monde entier des bandes dessinées on
peut penser plus tard au peanuts de
Charles Schulz par exemple qui vont
avoir une notoriété mais absolument
extraordinaire il y a pas un pays qui ne
connaît pas les donc ce sont des
personnages que les lecteurs et les
lectrices vont pouvoir s'approprier
vivre avec eux pendant des décennies
petit à petit on verra ensuite la bande
dessinée se spécialiser passer vers le
monde du livre avant le Japon pour nous
évidemment on pense que l'hypersentre de
la bande dessinée c'est la France et la
Belgique avec deux écoles disons ça
c'est pas dans votre livre c'est moi la
ligne claire le dessin réaliste Hergé
mais aussi Blake et Mortimer Alix et
puis les gros nez comme on disait les
personnages un peu caricaturés Astérix
ce Gaston lacaffe Spirou les trois
est-ce que je me trompe en disant que
les trois grandes figures de la bande
dessinée
franco-belge c'est Hergé c'est Franquin
et c'est un scénariste Goscinny qui a
fait notamment Astérix et Obélix oui
alors on a deux dates clés 1929
naissances de Tintin 1959 naissance
Astérix dans les deux cas ce sont des
bandes dessinées qui vont essaimer qui
vont donner naissance à énormément de
choses sans Hergé sans son succès
d'abord local puis international il y
aurait pas eu ce développement
extraordinaire de la bande dessinée en
Belgique avec les hebdomadaires Tintin
et Spirou qui sont finalement plus
proches que différents sanguini non
seulement un scénariste de génie mais un
animateur extraordinaire rédacteur en
chef qui a pilote va vraiment faire
passer la bande dessinée de l'enfance à
l'adolescence puis petit à petit de
l'adolescence à l'âge adulte je crois
qu'on n'aurait pas eu ces choses
évidemment vous citiez aussi Franquin
Franquin avec les aventures de Spirou
avec Gaston Lagaffe un génie graphique
voilà donc il y a des idées noires et
les idées noires à la fin de sa vie une
capacité d'évolution de de
transformation ce sont de très très
grandes figures qui ont permis à la
bande dessinée de trouver une expression
quand la critique de s'en occuper pas
beaucoup Christophe quels sont quel
était le maître pour vous quel était la
figure tutélaire quel est le dessinateur
ou l'auteur qui vous a inspiré donné
envie de faire de la bande dessinée
mon premier livre c'était un Lucky Luke
donc à ce moment-là je pourrais dire et
c'était le premier Lucky Luke donc je
pourrais dire que c'est Maurice qui a
inventé Lucky Luke avant de faire
beaucoup d'albums qui ont été très
célèbres avec les scénarios de Goscinny
au départ il les écrivait seul c'était
mon premier livre donc je peux dire que
c'est un livre fondateur et je me suis
rendu compte j'ai réalisé que j'étais
capable de lire seul de manière autonome
avec un Tintin avant je regardais les
albums comme ça sans comprendre où je me
les ai racontés en mettant sur les
genoux de qui une grand-mère une tente
ma mère mon père et un jour j'ai réalisé
que j'étais en train de lire un Tintin
Tintin et Lucky Luke diriger Maurice
essentiellement et egosigny après ont
été les gens qui m'ont formé et
personne ne m'a oublié maintenant
l'importance de pile gadget alors je
reviens à vous Benoît parce que vous
disiez il y a un continent qu'on a
découvert récemment nous Européens mais
qui existe depuis toujours qui est le
manga et qui a connu chez nous une
faveur incroyable alors le manga avait
un dieu au Japon comme nous on avait
Hergé Goscinny c'était Zucca Tesuka il
était universellement connu il
produisait du dessin animé mais surtout
des mangas dans tous les registres et il
a connu l'évolution et donc le succès de
Tezuka a permis à énormément de mangas
dans des vraiment des registres très
très divers de se développer dans des
séries immenses où finalement le récit
comptent encore plus que la perfection
du dessin parfois un petit malentendu
chez nous on croit que la bande dessinée
c'est d'abord l'art du dessin alors que
au Japon c'est d'abord la narration et
la première fois que Tesuka est venu au
Festival d'Angoulême il est passé
inaperçu la puce balader dans les rues
comme ça alors qu'au Japon c'était un
dieu vivant aujourd'hui
quand vous imaginez un grand manga qui
arrive à Angoulême c'est la star la
France et le deuxième pays du manga et
si la bande dessinée est considérée
comme aussi florissante si ces chiffres
sont aussi impressionnants c'est pas
seulement à cause du bon de sans fin
c'est aussi à cause d'une dizaine de
séries mangues qui ont un public
absolument colossal donc vraiment les
trois mondes de la bande dessinée le
monde européen le monde américain le
monde japonais aujourd'hui
coexistent et cohabitent pour les
auteurs comme pour les lecteurs aussi
c'est
l'évolutivité l'inventivité par exemple
le roman graphique c'est une éruption
assez récente c'est un produit efface
c'est une agent assez récent
novel puisque c'est comme ça qu'il est
apparu d'abord aux États-Unis notamment
avec maos Dar Spiegelman que vous citiez
c'est ce qui a ouvert à la bande
dessinée aux États-Unis la porte des
librairies et des bibliothèques parce
qu'au fond c'était des produits de
kiosque ou des produits de
collectionneurs le comic book c'était
vraiment un petit monde tout d'un coup
on s'est dit mais non ce sont de vrais
livres qui peuvent raconter de vraie
histoire de vraies choses alors bien sûr
il y a pas de frontières étanche entre
bandes dessinées et roman graphiques il
y a pas non plus une aristocratie du
genre il s'agit pas dire le roman
graphique c'est la bande dessinée chic
et l'autre c'est pour les ploucs c'est
pas du tout ça mais il se trouve qu'avec
des livres comme Persépolis par exemple
comme l'arabe du futur aujourd'hui on a
vu la bande dessinée touchée de nouveaux
publics particulièrement du côté des
femmes parce que pendant longtemps bah
la bande dessinée comme on la
connaissait c'était quand même plutôt
une affaire d'homme et tout d'un coup
avec des récits plus amples qui sont pas
forcément dans des séries les femmes se
sont mises en lire et en même temps en
produire
on pourrait poursuivre parce que
j'aurais aimé parler de gottliem
grand grand grand personnage de ce monde
d'Art Spiegelman de Claire bretech qui a
elle aussi une certaine manière à
accomplir une révolution mais si ceux
qui nous suivent poursuivre ce dialogue
avec vous je le recommande vivement de
lire ce petit livre qui est un prodige
à la fois de pédagogie d'illustration de
clarté et qui donne envie d'aller plus
loin la bande dessinée on l'a dit est
capable de d'être
une oeuvre de l'esprit
extraordinairement populaire on le sait
avec les 300 ou 400 millions
d'exemplaires vendus d'Astérix ou sans
doute de de Tintin mais vous venez de le
démontrer vous
Christophe Blin avec le monde sans fin
qui est vendu vous l'avez dit à 700 000
exemplaires au moment où on se parle
alors vous le racontez au début du livre
mais je voudrais que vous le redisiez
comment vous vous êtes allé je trouvais
un jour Janco comme on l'appelle et vous
allez nous dire qu'il est et vous avez
eu l'idée de lui proposer sa redites
nous d'abord qui il est et comment
l'idée cette idée tranche je vous ai
venu Jean-Marc Jean-Côme ici est un
ingénieur un polytechnicien l'ancien
politique technicien qui
qui un jour a
relativement fortuitement parce que
c'était pas sa recherche
initiales à découvert à l'occasion d'un
d'un emploi le lien qu'il y avait entre
les déplacements professionnels
quotidiens en France et
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
une époque là on parle du milieu ou du
début des années 90 ou gaz à effet de
serre était pas du tout un mot qu'on
entendait communément dans les médias et
dans les discussions et à partir de là
il s'est demandé mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça qu'est-ce que ça signifie
il a fait des recherches et il a il a
compris en interrogeant d'autres
scientifiques en allant au plus loin
possible
comment fonctionnait le principe des gaz
à effet de serre et donc du
réchauffement climatique et qui était
lié à l'utilisation d'énergie
essentiellement fossile
et à partir de là il s'est rendu compte
qu'il avait il a découvert quelque chose
qui n'a plus jamais lâché et il a créé
c'est la personne qui a créé ce qu'on
appelle le bilan carbone qui est utilisé
maintenant mondialement c'est à dire à
l'échelle individuelle à l'échelle d'une
entreprise d'une entité quels sont les
émissions qu'une personne qu'une
entreprise émet des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre comment on les calcule
voilà
et service parce que vous arrivez à lui
faire écrire enfin vous écrivez ensemble
le faire accoucher d'une histoire de
l'humanité à travers l'énergie et
notamment vous montrer comment
ces énergies fossiles je devrais pas
refaire toute cette histoire mais
comment ces énergies fossiles ont au
cours des deux derniers siècles
construit le monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui le la réduction du temps de
travail l'augmentation du revenu
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie la
fin de la de la sous-alimentation dans
le monde tout ça est un produit dans un
premier temps de la domestication et du
développement de ces énergies fossiles
oui c'est à dire que en fait j'ai
commencé le travail de ce avec Jean-Marc
parce que ça vient de mon frère mon
frère suivait ses conférences
depuis plusieurs années et il m'en
faisait régulièrement apprécie voilà moi
je n'y allais pas parce que ça
m'effrayait donc je faisais mon petit
déni dans un coin mais je l'écoutais et
puis j'ai développé en 2018 ce que je
raconte dans le livre une forme déco
anxiété c'est à dire que j'ai réalisé
que les épisodes caniculaires n'étaient
pas des épisodes accidentels comme on a
tous pu le connaître dans nos vies enfin
moi je suis né en 66 donc 70 dont je me
rappelle
76 j'étais gamin je me rappelle 2003
évidemment le j'étais déjà un grand
garçon ça arrive on a des épisodes
caniculaires et en 2018 c'est la
première fois que dans les médias ça
semble étonnant maintenant mais c'est la
première fois que dans les médias de
grande diffusion on mettait en relation
le réchauffement climatique et un
épisode caniculaire mon frère et moi on
a une très très grande complicité et il
m'a dit tu devrais faire un livre j'ai
quasiment fini la phrase avec
jean-marcosité c'était une évidence
quand il me l'a dit je savais mais je me
suis dit
j'ai su tout de suite que devant moi il
y avait un sacré boulot
le jour même ou le lendemain j'ai écrit
à Jean-Marc j'en connais j'avais
l'occasion d'avoir eu son contact et je
l'ai rencontré une semaine plus tard et
le livre a commencé on a commencé à
travailler ensemble
là entre-temps j'ai regardé ses
conférences que je plus par l'intérieur
de mon frère et on a commencé à
travailler ensemble alors il faut savoir
que c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait
accoucher de toutes ces histoires là
elles existaient déjà dans ces
conférences mais le fait que vous soyez
non pas ignorant mais profane et le fait
que vous ayez envie de le raconter d'une
manière amusante imagée ça ça permet de
faire cette histoire de l'énergie qui
d'abord nous construit et bientôt va
nous détruire d'une manière qui ne
s'était jamais vu jusqu'à présent c'est
une sorte de boîte de Pandore en fait
mais ce qui était intéressant dans le
fait de rencontrer Jean-Marc et pourquoi
j'ai voulu rencontrer Jean-Marc
Jancovici c'est que Jean-Marc Jancovici
lui-même avait déjà développé une
cosmogonie il avait déjà c'était
quelqu'un qui avait un imaginaire très
fort et dans il a c'est un vulgarisateur
exceptionnel parce qu'il arrive à faire
comprendre des complexes des concepts
extrêmement complexes
extrêmement vaste avec des images
lui-même utilise des images lui-même et
vraiment une forme de poète mais un
poète très en même temps très
pragmatique et on arrive dans une en
fait c'est un livre de transmission
pourquoi parce que quand on commence à
suivre ces conférences la première chose
qu'on a envie de faire c'est de le
raconter dans un dîner c'est de le
raconter autour d'une table évidemment
on n'arrive pas à le faire avec autant
de brio que lui on le fait on arrive à
prendre quelques éléments qui sont qui
sont frappants et puis très vite on dit
aux gens mais allez allez écouter ces
conférences en faisant un livre en
faisant un livre ça permet d'avoir une
transmission solide qu'on peut suivre à
son propre rythme et sur lequel on peut
revenir Benoît est-ce que ce livre
c'est-à-dire un livre engagé militant et
vont d'évangélisation mais en même temps
très drôle dans ce très très imagé dans
ces formules parce que en effet
Jean-Côme ici à l'art de résumé par
exemple l'énergie en équivalent esclave
il dit qu'en gros un Français moyen
utilise en énergie l'équivalent 600
esclaves
à son service bon bref il a l'air des
images il y a l'art du dessin de la
narration drôle et humoristique de
Christophe est-ce que ça ça inaugure un
genre nouveau où ce type de livre avait
déjà existé la bande dessinée c'est la
bande dessinée de non-fiction elle était
autrefois didactique c'était souvent
vraiment du travail de mercenaire pas
très bien fait tout d'un coup on voit
ces dernières années une capacité de la
bande dessinée par l'humour parce qu'à
cette dimension caricaturale dans le
travail de Christophe Blain mais aussi
par la schématisation l'idéographie
quelquefois il y a une capacité à
transmettre je crois que c'est une page
importante qui se tourne de Christophe
blinde d'une certaine façon avait
popularisé la politique avec français
nous avaient fait entrer dans les
coulisses d'un grand restaurant avec en
cuisine avec un impassard et on sent
chez lui comme chez d'autres que la
bande dessinée peut poser un débat de
société peut tout d'un coup être lu non
pas simplement comme une BD
divertissante puis comme une BD qui fait
penser avec laquelle on est d'accord pas
d'accord on fera en tout cas qui nous
interpelle qui nous qui nous je crois
que c'est une branche de la bande
dessinée qui va beaucoup beaucoup se
développer notamment grâce à l'immense
succès de ce livre évidemment l'effet de
tout ça c'est que vous entrez dans le
débat vous-même pour une fois vous
n'êtes pas simplement l'observateur et
d'ailleurs il y a eu des polémiques
normales d'ailleurs est-ce que je trouve
vous trouvez ça gênant que ça engendre
des polémiques ou au contraire c'était
un effet recherché de cette de cet
exercice alors pour être très honnête on
s'attendait à pire parce que Jean-Marc à
lutter beaucoup ils sont sont
son analyse à souvent été déformée et
mal comprise
et notamment autour de du nucléaire
on peut pas faire autrement d'en parler
parce que lui il a un regard très
pragmatique là-dessus il a pas il a pas
du tout de regard dogmatique justement
ici il pose les choses et puis il
commence à marche avec quoi on les met
en relation quel est le bilan quel est
le moins quel est le moins mauvais quel
est le meilleur voilà c'est comme ça qui
pose les choses on va poursuivre notre
conversation avec un lecteur une
lectrice en l'occurrence Gwenaëlle qui a
une question
à poser à l'un d'entre vous mais en fait
je crois qu'elle va la poser à tous les
deux Gwenaëlle on vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Gwenaëlle j'ai 19
ans je pense que je suis une une grande
lectrice Julie environ je pense de trois
livres par semaine j'essaie de changer
de genre assez assez régulièrement pour
vous pas rester dans un seul et même
type je suis en train de lire un livre
assez connu qui est du coup illusion
perdue de Balzac donc un peu une des
bases de littérature française et
j'avais déjà lu du Balzac avant mais
alors celui-ci c'est c'est quand même un
sacré chef-d'œuvre déjà de par
l'écriture le personnage auquel on
s'attache du coup l'histoire de ruban
pré est un personnage très ambivalent et
à laquelle on se pose beaucoup de
questions c'est à dire où est-ce que
Balzac a publié son inspiration pour
nous créer un personnage qui est à la
fois détestable mais à la fois
appréciable à mes yeux c'est justement
une question que j'aurais posé à à de ma
vitesse du coup qui est comment
comment arriver en fait à ce processus
création de personnages notamment dans
cette idée obscures du coup quand même
on volait de mémoire où il y a des
personnages très bien construits et je
voudrais savoir où est-ce que notre père
arrive à puiser du coup ses inspirations
pour pour créer ces personnages
merci merci beaucoup
pour moi la bande dessinée ça a toujours
été d'abord un acte de complicité de
collaboration j'ai un ami qui est non
seulement un merveilleux dessinateur
donc François skitten je suis mais qui a
aussi beaucoup d'idées et on échange
ensemble on ping pong pendant que je
commence à écrire il fait des esquisses
du personnage on le voit on le visualise
ensemble parfois il m'arrive de jouer
les scènes de les mimer devant lui et
qui prend des croquis et voilà petit à
petit un personnage qui prend vie alors
ce qui est amusant c'est que quand nous
étions jeunes France toi et moi on
faisait des personnages assez h et assez
massif et maintenant que nous prenons un
peu d'âge nos personnages rajeunissent
alors après le point de vue d'un auteur
le point de vue de la dessinateur où
c'est quoi alors évidemment pas là parce
que mais par exemple
en fait le pour moi l'expression du pour
raconter une histoire se passe autant
par les mots que par le dessin est
généralement elle quand je travaille
mais même quand je travaille en
opération je suis toujours qu'aux
scénariste et elle commence généralement
par des mots par des dialogues oui et la
création d'un personnage souvent vient
d'impression de rencontres et de un
mélange de moi-même mais c'est souvent
des gens qui existent vraiment ou alors
la synthèse de plusieurs personnes mais
c'est des vrais gens que je fais parler
et que j'entends et qui au bout d'un
moment les
scénaristes disent souvent des choses
comme ça des gens qui prennent leur
indépendance alors qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire prendre son indépendance
c'est-à-dire que au départ on se fait un
grille du personnage que ça va être on
le définit son caractère on est comme ça
et en fait il prend son indépendance à
partir du moment où on va lui faire
faire quelque chose de surprenant pour
nous-mêmes merci merci alors cette
émission s'achève mais on ne va pas se
quitter sans avoir partagé nos coups de
cœur avec ceux qui nous ont suivis
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut vous leur donniez vraiment envie
de lire quelque chose qui le mérite
Christophe on commence par vous quel est
votre coup de coeur de la semaine je
conseillerais les aventures d'un
scénariste à Hollywood d'un très un
scénariste légendaire qui s'appelle
William Goldman c'est un livre qui l'a
écrit en deux périodes distinctes il a
commencé dans les années 70 une première
paix où il racontait c'était le
scénariste par exemple de grands succès
comme but Cassidy et le Kid les hommes
du président
Marathon Man qui a été adapté l'un de
ses propres livres et c'est auto-adapté
etc etc Princess bryse après etc et il a
raconté dans un premier temps ses
aventures d'une manière
drôleissime et très franche avec
beaucoup de recul et beaucoup
d'autodérision à tel point que ça lui
avoue value d'être totalement tricard
pendant presque une dizaine d'années à
Hollywood il a été quelqu'un est venu le
rechercher parce que c'est un scénariste
de très grand talent en disant c'est
vraiment dommage que vous soyez dans
cette situation là et il raconte la
seconde voilà Benoît votre coup de cœur
de la semaine alors on parlait de roman
graphique on parlait de féminisation de
la bande dessinée moi mon coup de coeur
c'est la vie gourmande d'Aurélia orita
alors Aurélia orita peut-être certaines
et certains se souviennent d'elle finir
un petit peu de sulfureuse avec une
porte dessinée érotique mais très drôle
en même temps que ça plaît fraise et
chocolat elle a mûri
et la vie gourmande est un livre
extraordinaire parce qu'il relie deux
choses et relient la gourmandise le
vraiment le plaisir de la nourriture
d'abord en immersion dans un grand
restaurant puis dans les souvenirs de
toute sa vie cuisine japonaise cuisine
familiale et la traversée de la maladie
il y a la traversée d'un cancer du sein
qui pourrait être un épisode absolument
douloureux mais qui racontait sous
l'angle du goût la fin du livre est
absolument sublime mais vous met les
larmes aux yeux voilà c'est un livre qui
m'a beaucoup touché merci beaucoup alors
un public nous nous avons aimé cette
semaine de soyevski le soleil noir aux
éditions Futuropolis Chantal Vanden
Heuvel et Henric raire c'est un
biographie de de ce yefski qui qui
ont adoré de sigmunes Freud à Hemingway
en passant par ça très et je ne sais qui
encore enfin dont tout le monde
considère qu'il est le grand génie russe
et Franquin créa la gaffe nu massadou
les André Franquin c'est une réédition
d'un livre mythique chez Glénat ce sont
des longs entretiens
que Franquin avait accordé à une masse à
doulle et on l'a dit tout à l'heure
Franquin est un génie fantastique à la
fois dans la partie gay
Spirou mais aussi dans la partie sombre
il devait être il devait avoir une zone
de dépression en lui de ténèbres et les
idées noires c'est un livre passionnant
sur ce qu'est la création de la bande
dessinée la fabrique des héros
chez Dupuis c'est son temps d'édition de
Dupuis donc Dupuis je ne vous les donne
pas ces livres parce que je suis sûr que
vous avez déjà je vais les garder pour
moi sauf si vous en voulez un vous me le
dites Dupuis c'est l'un des Cent Ans
donc d'une édition qui est née à
Bruxelles et qui qui a édité Spirou
Gaston Lagaffe Lucky Luke Dany et tant
d'autres encore c'est l'une des maisons
phares du monde de de la bande dessinée
et en 100 petites histoires on raconte
l'histoire de cette maison et de la
bande dessinée et enfin Nine Antico
madonnes et [__]
c'est un livre très très fort qui se
litre féminisme enfin qui raconte disons
la violence faite aux femmes à partir de
figures de Saintes du sud de l'Italie
dont on raconte l'histoire pour montrer
de quoi elle est faite c'est un livre
remarquable voilà cette émission
s'achève merci à Christophe Blin merci à
Benoît Peters pour votre initiation
enfin pour avoir partagé avec nous votre
goût de cette bande dessinée qui n'est
certainement plus un art mineur vous
l'avez démontré l'un et l'autre merci à
Gwenaëlle qui nous a qui nous a
interrogé merci à vous qui nous avait
suivi vous pouvez revoir cette émission
sur le site de publicité Nao sur votre
plateforme préférée et nous nous
revoyons nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine à moins que nous nous soyons
croisés d'ici là dans une librairie
merci et bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]